so Magnus has talked to you about
indexes and how every query needs to
have an index so let's see what happens
if you deploy an application to apps
part that requires a new index so what
we're going to do is update our filter
playground method you may have called
this method something else but this is
the method where you've been adding your
hard wyd filters anyway we're going to
update it to filter for another thing so
for example let's filter for conferences
in June so we just filter on month
equals 6 because the month is recorded
by an integer and 6 is June after you've
added this filter go ahead and deploy
your application directly to appspot in
this case do not run the query on
localhost first I know I've been telling
you always run it on localhost first but
now I want you to see what happens if
you don't so don't run it on localhost
just run it directly on appspot try
running your query in the API Explorer
what happens